okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 starting today with our caller
from the six one five area code who's
calling today from six one five hi David
this is um Jack and I know this is a
natural area cope I'm currently on
vacation and Connecticut visiting family
oh all right well Connecticut's due
treating you well yeah thank you for
taking my call um so I had a couple
questions I'll make them as brief as I
can so you talked a lot about the $15
minimum wage and that is one of I think
the top priorities I think the next
president should a Democrat get elected
enact in Congress and in the Oval Office
so but I see a lot of conflicting
studies like studies that say oh it's
good for the worker does not reduce
hours does not significantly sit nah
yeah sorry significantly reduce
employment benaiah see selasa is saying
the exact opposite but the one thing I
observe about those studies that say
it's bad for the worker bad for
entry-level workers is that they are
funded by the restaurant industry well
if you point that out to them the
rebuttal is oh but your studies are
funded by labor unions so how do you
determine whether a study is actually
unbiased and factual and there's not a
conflict of interest skewing they're
almost always will be some potential
conflict or bias in almost any study the
question is to figure out is there a
particular way in which it is
influencing the results and with
something like the minimum wage you can
basically get whatever results you want
my view tends to be in looking at what I
would consider to be the most sort of
disconnected from biased funding
academic type studies what I am seeing
is that the if there is an effect on
hours and employment to a higher minimum
wage depending on how much the minimum
wage is increasing beyond its status quo
so in a state with a lower cost of
living and a lower minimum wage like
Arkansas going from
you know 8 to 15 dollars is going to
have a much bigger impact than it is in
a state where the minimum wage is
already for example 11 dollars and 15
are you ibly may not even be a living
wage still so there is that that's the
issue that it's a very regionalised
affect that you need to be looking much
more specifically and just because there
is some negative impact to a policy that
doesn't mean it's a policy we shouldn't
do think about how many policies we
enact all the time that have some costs
but we determine the benefits outweigh
the costs if that makes sense Jack that
makes absolute sense and that was what I
was reading on the Economic Policy
Institute where they were saying that
that oh like there might be very very
small cost to it but the benefits far
outweigh it but then the reason I was
asking is because I saw this very
interesting old segment that Kyle
kolinsky did back in 2013 I came across
it recently where Chris Hayes was
talking about how there was a this group
called the employment policies Institute
that sounded you know academic and
serious but really they were just a PR
forum for the restaurant lobbying
industry and he's brought on this guy
everywhere this guy named Michael
Saltzman no yeah he writes Lava Beds
saying all the minimum wage is terrible
and all the things you hear will kill
jobs well that's the main point he makes
but Chris Hayes is like the studies
you're citing are bought and paid for by
the restaurant lobbying industry and
Kyle was Kyle said in his segment light
bulb that's what they do they they pay
for fake studies to get the results that
they want and then they have so that
they have a fake intellectual leg to
stand on so that they say well we would
love to raise the minimum wage and count
our profits but we have to say this is
it it's a bad idea so sorry yes they do
I'm gonna move all right Jack thank you
so much appreciate the call I've got a
bun are people waiting but I do hope to
hear from you again